es kann jetzt losgeht sie geht auf die
andere seite von dem bett beide ziehen
sie aus nein
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video hier spielen heute etwas was ich
schon sehr sehr lange nicht mehr
gespielt habe viele leute haben jetzt
nicht mal wieder gewünscht und 24
wir sehen schon das ist ein neues haus
hier das problem ist dass ich meine sims
4 datei leider verloren habe einen neuen
pc herum so aber hey ich hab mein papa
im garten das ist eigentlich schon
ausgleich genug da ich die datei nicht
mehr habe habe ich erst mal ein neues
haus gebaut
wer hat denn dann penis in den garten
gemalt das hier ist mein neu gebautes
haus wenn ich mal hier in den bau modus
hier seht ihr das hat auch so ein cooles
ein bisschen südländisches dach wenn wir
waren auf di luca draufklicken sehen wir
schon der ist da allein gott ist das ein
opfer alter hat mir auf jeden fall neuen
luca kreiert der bund jetzt hier in
diesem neuen haus und ich würde sagen
das heutige ziel der heutigen folge ist
es dass luca sich jemanden klärt
[Applaus]
deswegen kommen luca wir gehen wir nach
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
luca dies lies diese können sie dir
können sie die leute gekommen luca luca
luka show mein gott leute sie laufen
aufeinander zulaufen aneinander vorbei
luca wie läuft überhaupt ok luca wir
lassen doch lieber die hände von ihr sie
macht liegestuhl auch gott jetzt stellt
er sich der trotzdem vorbei wenn wir
unsere hände schütteln macht das voll
viel spaß ja dass das ist hammer das
könnt ihr wirklich machen schau mal das
ist mein gesicht davon dass mehr als das
denn gott ja ich finde das eine
mülltonne ist ich habe im bett bei mir
da könnten wir theoretisch ein bisschen
drin schlafen ich weiß nicht das stinkt
dann natürlich auch nach müll genauso
wie meine zähne müll nämlich genau meine
zähne ich habe luca jetzt einfach mal
gesagt dass er sie fragen soll ob sie
lust hat mit ihm abzuhängen das heißt er
mich deutsche mal wieder die
unterhaltung da wir könnten videospiele
spielen oder com kraft auf youtube zu
schauen oder wir könnten bücher essen
weil ich es voll gern bücher und geld
schießt gold digger das ist nicht wahr
luca lässt sie jetzt gehen sie läuft
hier die ganze dran vorbei und warum bei
luca auf toilette muss luca ist das
update nachdem luca fertig ist auf
toilette steht er jetzt vom grill luca
du kannst nicht grillen nancy landgraf
ist dieses mädel die ich hier ist luca
mazzella vorn in der küche was zu essen
ok haben luca flöten kannst du auf jeden
fall luca hat gegessen ist wie immer
super unterwegs setzt sich jetzt einfach
da vorne hin was ist denn mit der frau
was macht sie an meinem computer sie
geht zu luca die beiden chillen dort die
lagern so ein bisschen würde sagen wir
gehen jetzt mal so ein bisschen tiefer
ins gespräch rein dh vom herzen kommen
das kompliment mal machen die sonne ist
ein richtig heißer planet genauso heiß
wie du könnten in deinem bett gehen
und chili cheese sandwiches machen was
hältst du davon luca ich will
videospiele spielen also bisher sieht
unser haushalt so aus dass luca alleine
in dem esszimmer hier seine hamburger
ist und die wir uns eigentlich klären
wollten computer spielt wir geben den
man noch ein bisschen zeit so weil sie
nicht so ein paar sekunden und dann
versuchen das noch mal mit dem flirten
ein paar sekunden später ich muss mit
ihr ja so ein bisschen diesen balken
hier oben größer kommen also jetzt
gerade sind weder freund noch feind
einfach eine ganz normale beziehung
deswegen bin ich mir jetzt so viel zeit
wie möglich verbringen damit wird
vielleicht einseitigen folgenden beiden
zusammen
und wer so ein kleines shipping pärchen
haben ich habe es jetzt aber gefragt ob
sie mit mir nicht abhängen will und sie
meint ja das heißt wir gehen jetzt
glaube ich zusammen zurück zu mir kommen
bitte geht zurück zu mir leute bitte da
können wir irgendwas anderes machen aber
nicht wild punkte auf diesen blöd
bürgersteig rumstehen und wenn ich im
bett liege spiele ich meistens mit
meinem eigenen kleinen hand warum aber
da so siehst du also aus da es ja dieser
komische spaß die alter er läuft einfach
durch bild bleibt stehen geht gianluca
du glaubst sie nicht gehen lassen man
ich bin geil klärte mich doch vielleicht
ich habe auch einen geilen panzern in
der hose sie geht wieder von luca weg ab
in die küche gönnt sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich was von meinem ham burger
oder ist kein problem dar warum habt ihr
euch also ich meine das ist gut aber
jetzt erzählt euch wieder irgendwas über
cds alter ihr sollte einfach mal rum
machen was ist denn hier kommt radfahren
bisschen unternehmen fasst zusammen nur
eine gewöhnliche höfliche konversation
versucht zu plaudern und warte ab was
geschieht wie so können wir nicht
einfach uns lieben oder so hey du hast
ein hammer daumen
justin hammer sportwagen luca mega cool
du hast zwei jahre sport wegen auch sehr
sehr geil luca ich geschlafen
luca du bleibst jetzt bei ihr mann leute
übrigens wenn euch gefällt und ihr
findet dass sich das auf das hochladen
soll dann las man fetten like da und bei
400 millionen bis 400 millionen likes ja
dann kommt neuer bat ich gestehe er die
einfach mal dass ich mich angezogen von
gefühle also auch wieder so ein bisschen
auf diese romantik pur auf diese flirten
tue
nein nein schweizer neuer tag neues
glück liebe freunde lukas ausgeschlafen
weit und breit keine spur von nancy
nancy sie hier ist lukas wollte nicht
mal irgendwie an funkeln oder irgendwie
sowas machen
ich habe ganz schön große glocken luca
das ist doch arg getrübt wird die brust
drückt dann gesicht das hast du auch
luca er zwinkert ihr ein paar herzchen
zu sie findet das ganze wieder ganz nah
ist das ganze läuft wieder warum denkst
dann schlechtes wetter
was ist los für die leute ich werde
jetzt einfach noch mal so ein bisschen
mit der hilfe warten bis sie mit der
lahn und wir sehen uns dann wieder wenn
das ganze was gebracht hat oder halt
auch nicht eine ewigkeit später okay
leute es ist gerade folgende situation
mit dem nennt sie läuft alles super so
wir haben uns schon gekürzt werden
händchen gehalten aber jetzt ist sich
irgendwie weggelaufen weil da eine
andere ich am start ist der player luca
hat sich eine andere geklärt sie hier
vorne läuft weg sich ist aber eigentlich
auch ganz 90 märkten bei den namens
summer holiday okay das ist ein
richtiger name aber wir haben mal wieder
so ein bisschen mit der nancy und der
luca will ihr jetzt eine rose geben oh
mein gott jetzt job tier zusammen wollt
ihr mich verarschen dicker hier oben
steht dass wir einen erotischen
austausch haben meine damen und herren
vielleicht wird es in dieser folge noch
was luca räumt hier gerade so ein
bisschen alles auf und sie wartet da
fordern der küche okay die beiden nähern
sich wieder die beiden mögen sich also
wirklich luca stinkt so ein bisschen das
heißt ich würde sagen wir gehen erst mal
in die badewanne baden und so ein
bisschen sie kann noch mitkommen
oder geht das luca ist frisch gebadet es
ist 18 uhr
leute wir kommen zum finale das heißt
die beiden treffen sich wieder lagern so
ein bisschen sind bei einem sinnlichen
austausch bürger gesteht ihr seine liebe
oh mein gott leute haben ja steigt dann
steigt steigt okay ich glaube sie es
jetzt irgendwas von dinosauriern luca
geh zu ihr ans bett sie liegt hier doch
ganz alleine und nein das ist nicht sein
herz ich würde am liebsten mit ihr
zusammen kuscheln aber ich will sie
nicht aufwecken ich würde trotzdem sagen
dass die folge endlich mal ein ende
kommen deswegen klicke ich jetzt doch
wirklich auf becken
wir schauen mal wie sie reagiert sie
steht auf ist wieder gut gelaunt und ich
würde sagen wir funkeln sie jetzt
einfach mal wie so könnt ihr nicht
einfach irgendwie euch mal lieben die
beiden hören sich wirklich
ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt aber
ein spitzbübisches an dingen sind ich
spiele noch was die zeit so ein bisschen
vor
dann machen wir nochmal so ein bisschen
nein es hat gar nicht funktioniert wir
haben hat minuspunkte bekommen luca zog
schon wieder sie sitzt hier vorne auf
dem pott ich würde trotzdem sagen wir
probieren es leute wir müssen es in
dieser folge doch irgendwie hinkriegen
mit ihr irgendwie uns zu küssen oder so
zumindest
wir haben es geschafft die beiden sind
hier vorne noch ein bisschen rum technik
und beim bett hier vorne die
techtelmechtel ii
ich würde sagen wir selbst uns erst mal
hierhin und plaudern die beiden laufen
auf das bett zu setzen sich dort erst
mal hin lagern so ein bisschen
das heißt ich würde ich weiß ich hab mir
da schon barrikaden die klingt erstmal
auf massieren
vielleicht gefällt dir das jahr wenn
luca sie so ein bisschen passiert okay
okay okay ihr gefällt es anscheinend
okay es macht ihr spaß sie findet es
toll jetzt mit ich sagen mach mir ein
bisschen rum schmusen die beiden umarmen
sich sie schmusen rum und jetzt leute
jetzt geht's los ich klicke jetzt auf
techtelmechtel mit nancy land grab okay
leute es kann sein das passiert jetzt
ist kann sein das ist jetzt passiert die
beiden küssen sich noch ein bisschen wir
warten mal ab leute also sie haben wir
jetzt aufgehört sich zu küssen und jetzt
denken sie beide an liebe sie gibt ihnen
kurz er geht ins bett und sie geht nach
hause
nein du bleibst hier das kann doch nicht
sein wir sind die ganze zeit kurz davor
das unmögliche in einer folge zu
schaffen also einkommen rabatt ein
bisschen hier das dass sich eine
freundin der ok sie freut sich ich habe
jetzt eine freundin das heißt wir
klicken jetzt einfach mal auf rose
anbieten da freut sie sich bestimmte
ware rose und jetzt leute wie klicken
jetzt auf was war heiratsantrag nennt
sie ist bereits verheiratet mutter von
sie hat schon freund nennen sie liegt
alleine im bett das heißt ich wecke sich
jetzt einfach mal auf leute es muss
jetzt leider so sein nennt sie jetzt
kommen doch alter warum geht sie denn
jetzt dahinter und will barbecue machen
man okay leute die beiden laufen nach
drinnen nicht zumal schon mal auf sagt
dran wir können erst jetzt wirklich
sehen leute es kann jetzt losgeht sie
geht auf die andere seite von dem
weltweit ziehen sie aus sie gehen
zusammen ins bett
edith clancy geist lancy isreal shipping
everywhere jetzt kennen die beiden hier
und ich glaube es hat beiden sehr sehr
viel spaß gemacht an der stelle würde
ich auch sagen das war's mit dem
heutigen video meine damen und herren
ich habe einfach gedacht das wird so
viele teams viel gefordert deswegen
fange ich jetzt mal wieder neu an wir
haben eine freundin am start wir haben
auch mit ihr schon rum machen können
also wenn es euch gefallen hat dass auf
jeden fall mal einen fetten like daher
findet jetzt hier ein zwei die
eingeblendete könnt ihr einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren keine videos mehr
zu verpassen wäre auf jeden fall mehr
ganz auf meinen shop eingeblendet virgin
es gibt und hier unten ist ein anderes
video verlinkt kann einfach so 50
minuten aufgenommen